streitpunkt berliner wohnungsmarkt hier
lockt das große geld wer es sich leisten
kann immobilien zukaufen profitiert von
steigenden preisen allerdings viele
berliner leben in angst ihr zuhause zu
verlieren denn die mieten sind
explodiert zwölf euro pro quadratmeter
bei neuvermietungen in der innenstadt
bis das keine seltenheit mehr
kenny kopf zeit unter vier euro pro
quadratmeter
ihr mietvertrag ist fast 30 jahre alt
ihr problem das haus muss dringend
saniert werden
sie haben es ja gesehen dach ist undicht
fassade muss gemacht werden viele haben
nach ofenheizung ihr müsst ihr mir nicht
zu sagen hast du doch dann mehr miete
dann bliebe nicht genug zum leben sagt
jenny kopf sie würde sich verkleinern
aber auch das geht nicht selbst kleinere
wohnungen sind in ihrem stadtteil
inzwischen teurer
wo sollen wir bleiben ja gibt vielleicht
einige die jetzt noch studenten haben
wir ja im haus sehr gut vielleicht wenn
die glück nie fertig studiert haben die
verdienen hörgenuss presse die miete
bezahlen kann aber ich nicht und einige
hier auch nicht ganz viele hier muss
nicht das haus im berliner norden hat
gerade den besitzer gewechselt seit
wenigen monaten gehört es dem
immobilienunternehmer jakob mehren
schon vor zwei jahren hat er mit uns
über den berliner wohnungsmarkt
gesprochen als immobilienhai zieht er
sich nicht seine mieter seien für ihn
partner sagt er
so erklärt er seine geschäftspolitik
unser geschäftsmodell basiert nicht
darauf dass wir den mieter rauswerfen
und die wohn und dann verkaufen sondern
im gegenteil ohne den mieter könnten wir
dieses geschäft nicht betreiben in der
regel tun wir was für den mieter werden
entwickeln das haus wir machen
eigentlich das gesamte objekt wohnlicher
ja und wenn es umgekehrt stand hat oder
auch leerstand bekommt weil einfach
leute kündigen oder ausziehen sanieren
wenn der regel die wohnungen wenn sie im
unsanierten zustand sind und vermieten
diese dann neu in der regel wenn wir
geld investieren wird noch klar und um
wie viel teurer wird das zuhause von
jenny kopf er meint investoren brauchen
gesetzliche schranken
baustadtrat florian schmidt setzt auf
den sogenannten milieu schutz
praktisch heißt das luxussanierungen
verboten
das ziel der regelung einkommensschwache
mieter sollen weiter im stadtzentrum
wohnen können
das ist aber für die bauindustrie die ja
auch gleich den immobilien industrie
sind für die ist es natürlich schädlich
fürs geschäft und die sagen dann oh gott
enteignung
das ist ja aber sozialismus oder
ähnliches und na ja wir haben hier
eigentlich nichts weiter zu tun als dass
wir eine stadtentwicklung voran bringen
wo menschliches maß irgendwie
beibehalten wir dass die menschen eine
heimat haben und es nicht
auseinanderbricht was auch den sozialen
zusammenhalt betrifft in berlin brodelt
es die fronten zwischen mietern und
vermietern haben sich längst verhärtet
die begehrten innenstadtlagen sind hart
umkämpft
berlin reagiert mit einer ausweitung der
schutzgebiete
hier hat die stadt unter bestimmten
bedingungen sogar ein vorkaufsrecht darf
also häuserblocks selbst kaufen um sie
gegen spekulationen zu sichern
eine kehrtwende vor einigen jahren noch
hat die stadt selbst ihre
sozialwohnungen privatisiert
wenn wir zurückschauen in die
vergangenheit dann stellen wir natürlich
fest es ist ein skandal was passiert ist
berlin hat hunderttausende von wohnungen
verkauft das sind jetzt die wohnung wo
wir mit mit konzern und wiederum über
den milieus schutz verhandeln dass sie
dort ihre modernisierungsumlage senken
dass die mieten nicht zu sehr steigen im
zuge der aufwertung dass es schon ein
absurdes theater die neuen
schutzregelungen kommen allerdings spät
und was sie im einzelfall bedeuten muss
oft vor gericht geklärt werden
und jenny kopf was hat ihr neuer
hauseigentümer vor
wir haben bei der mehreren ag
nachgefragt die antwort
selbstverständlich muss das haus früher
oder später saniert werden
wir halten uns an das gesetz an die
milieu schutz satzung damit ist der
schutz der mieter in diesem gebäude so
hoch wie kaum sonst in deutschland
die mieter allerdings fürchten übles sie
haben sich zu einem verein
zusammengeschlossen und wollen sich
wehren mit der hausverwaltung schreibt
man sich böse briefe
das klima ist vergiftet jenny kopf will
darum kämpfen in ihrem gewohnten kiez
bleiben zu können
ja